richard is with us in Kansas City hi
Richard welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
my name's Richard medellín and I've got
myself in a pickle you got two credit
cards maxed out and there's they're
assuming me now I'm wondering what
happens when they put a judgment on me
well in most states they can garnish
your wages okay I'm on Social Security
disability so mm-hmm
I'm worried about what they're going to
do to the house I only know about 10,000
on it and you know it's only worth about
30 or 40 it would be unvarying usual
like almost would never happen that they
would mess with your house I would not
worry about that the one thing I have
seen them do in situations like yours is
if your Social Security Disability is
direct deposited into a checking account
they might put a lien on that checking
account they cannot scarf your Social
Security disability they can't touch it
but they can clean out checking accounts
and so if it's direct deposited and they
happen to have a lien on that account
boom they're gonna take that money so
how much is owed on these credit cards
about 9,000 between both of them okay
and how long has it been since you paid
on them last year okay
why were you able to pay then and you're
not able to pay now well I was paying
$250 a month on them and it was just
killing me and I tried to file
bankruptcy but the lawyers ripped me off
and she told me she could do would do
with chapter 7 but this changed your
mind said I had to do a chapter 13 yeah
I don't I don't think that was the
lawyer ripping you off I mean she may
have made a mistake but the law dictates
that in certain situations you have to
do a 13 versus a 7 and the lawyer
doesn't have a choice in that
so it wasn't it wasn't her changing that
on you so you're single yeah and so your
social security disability is how much
about 1,500 a month and that's what you
live on yes you don't have any other
money no coming in how old are you
people what's the nature of your
disability I have see what palsy and I
work for 30 years for deffenbaugh
jumping in out of a big truck or now I
could no longer do that so I've been on
disability since about oh wait mm-hmm
okay all right cool
you know basically you are in a position
that what we call judgment proof meaning
that there's not much they can get from
you
you do need to manage the checking
account as I mentioned and not let them
get a shot at the money that goes into
that checking account and I'm guessing
your direct deposit on that and go
straight into a checking account that
you used to live on and so you if Social
Security still has this available if
they actually do take a judgment lien
and if they start messing around I
wouldn't fool with it unless they did
but if they start messing around your
checking account you may want to go to a
paper process where you actually receive
a check in the mail and go to the bank
and cash it and that way there'd be no
way they could get that money the good
news is if you could scrape together
some money at some point from a side job
or something else you could probably get
them to settle this whole thing for
1,500 or 2,000 dollars you probably get
it settled for you know we're talking 10
20 cents on the dollar here and I think
I think that's very doable but that's
going to be tough to scratch together in
your situation so but if you scratch
that together you can probably call them
and explain your situation
I'm honed disability due to several
palsy this is my 54 I'm not able to work
I have $15 a month income that you do
not have access to on this one I'm
offering to settle this with you for
this you know $1,400 I've scraped
together or whatever it is and get that
in writing from them before you send
them money and if you get it in writing
then you send the money you're proof
that you sent the money
then at that point you you you know you
would have cleared the thing and settled
it in full that's your best case
scenario your worst case scenario is
you're looking over your shoulder for a
while and making sure that they're not
needling around in something but you
don't have a lot for them to get and so
they're not gonna mess with you much
they just don't they'll hassle you
they'll bother you they've been doing
that already but there's not a lot you
know you're kind of judgment proof as I
said